ZEB HOGAN: Think
sharks are scary?
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Well, this monster fish can
eat a shark in a single gulp!
MAN: Oh! Oh! Oh, my God!
ZEB HOGAN: Weighing as
much as a grand piano,
this territorial giant makes
headlines when it's hungry!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Amateur video show goliath
grouper aggressively eating
anything and everything
floating on the surface.
And craziest of all,
attacking scuba divers.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Once fished to near extinction,
these protected ocean giants are
reclaiming their home turf.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
So, I'm in Florida to catch a
super-sized goliath grouper
and see if it really is the
monster it's made out to be!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Oh, my God, it's huge!
Known internationally as a
fishing and dive capital
of the world, people here
in Florida love to play in
and around the water.
But some people think there's a
potential monster-sized problem
lurking beneath the surface
and it's not a shark!
By the mid-1990s, goliath
grouper were so overfished,
they became listed as
critically endangered.
So, under current U.S. law,
it's illegal to handle or
remove one from the water.
So, to see how these
giants really behave,
I'm gonna need to
call in the experts.
I'm out with Chris Malinowski
and a research team
from Florida State University.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Very little is known about
these sumo-sized fish.
So, Chris is trying to
learn where they live,
what they eat and whether
or not this protected giant
is actually making a comeback.
Not only is his research crucial
for their future survival,
but it's the only way I
can legally examine one.
I don't see any
fishing rods on board,
how are we gonna
catch these fish?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: The
easiest way that we've found
to catch them is actually
through using a hand line.
It's basically a rope.
ZEB HOGAN: We're gonna be
catching grouper
with a hand line.
This is big, heavy duty
gear, a thick rope,
nine hundred pound
monofilament line.
And then, pretty much the
largest circle hook you can buy.
Look how big that hook is.
We wanna be able to
out-muscle the grouper,
as soon as I feel a bite, I'm
gonna get into a tug-of-war
with the grouper and I'm trying
to get it up to the surface.
Is there a chance we'll catch
fish other than grouper?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: There's a lot
of different shark species
in this area that we
end up pulling up.
ZEB HOGAN: Some of
them pretty big?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Some
big, I mean, we've caught
14 foot hammerhead
during our last trip,
so these are massive fish.
ZEB HOGAN: Wow.
Sharks are a whole
different game.
When they get to the surface,
unlike goliath grouper,
sharks will use their
jaw, their sharp teeth,
they'll swing their
head and bite down!
So, if we catch one, we'll only
wanna bring it halfway
into the boat to unhook it,
before releasing it
back into the ocean.
What bait are we gonna use?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: So, we're
going to start off with a huge
chunk of Bonita here.
Okay. So, it's very important
when you're doing this
because we're catching
such large fish,
you've always gotta
watch your feet,
'cause if a fish
or a shark grabs,
it'll take you right
into the water.
ZEB HOGAN: Okay.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: So,
just chuck it over.
All right. Then hold on to
that mono,
keeping that in front of you,
good.
ZEB HOGAN: If that float starts
bobbing or goes underneath
the water, that's an indication
that I have a big fish.
But I have no way of knowing
if I've hooked a shark
or a goliath grouper.
I just know that it's
gonna be a big fight.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Wow, there we go, got one!
Fish!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
It's coming towards the
boat, hand over hand.
If it's a grouper, it's
gonna be a monster.
Oh, oh, here we go.
Shaking, shaking.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
It's coming up, can
feel it tug,
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
shaking.
Oh, I see white, it's
a shark, it's spinning.
Oh.
Woo! Man!
Sandbar shark, see the huge
dorsal fin on the back,
that's characteristic
of a sandbar shark.
Making another run!
We're gonna try to get this
into the boat head-first.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Okay, hold,
that's enough, that's enough,
that's enough.
JESS: I got it. I got it.
ZEB HOGAN: Yeah? There you go.
Yeah. It's a big, probably
seven, eight feet long,
you can see the big
dorsal fin, big pec fins.
Watch out!
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Got slapped
in the face that was fun!
ZEB HOGAN: And these
sharks, they can twist,
they'll throw up their
head, you can see,
if it senses something close
to it, it'll bite down.
So, right there,
it's kind of blocked,
it can't really move its head
too much and twist around
for a bite, so this is the
safest place to keep the shark.
Got a tag?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Got one.
ZEB HOGAN: We're
gonna clip the hook,
so it doesn't have its
hook in its jaw anymore.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Let's go.
ZEB HOGAN: Okay,
it's ready to go.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Ready?
ZEB HOGAN: Nice.
Good work, guys.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Yeah.
That was good.
ZEB HOGAN: That really
was a monster of the deep,
but I wanna know if the goliath
grouper's bite is just as big.
So, it's time to
bait up and cast out.
Ugh, fish!
Oh!
Gah, it feels like we
hooked onto an anchor!
Go round the other side?
Ugh!
It's running. It's running.
Watch it, watch it,
watch it, watch it.
Let it go, let it go, let it go.
Waaaa.
It's a large shark, big
Dusky, it's hard to maneuver,
it's probably eight
or nine feet long.
JESS: Watch it, watch it.
[INAUDIBLE]
ZEB HOGAN: Here it is.
You got the tail rope?
JESS: Yeah, nice.
ZEB HOGAN: We got
it, let him go!
Hey, we got the tail, so now,
we can control it a little bit
easier, and we're gonna bring
it in tail-first into the boat.
It's a really beautiful shark.
Watch out.
Got it?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Here
we go, here we go!
ZEB HOGAN: Oh, my God.
We got to cut the hook out.
Woo, man!
[LAUGHTER]
That was a big fish!
Sharks are clearly an
apex predator out here.
They're so quick to our bait.
We're gonna need to drop more
hooks to increase our chances
of catching a goliath grouper.
Oh.
Fish on.
Oh, man!
Fish.
It's really heavy.
It's hard to hold on to it.
That really is like
tug of war, isn't it?
Feel free to help me.
Three people, three of us.
Goliath grouper can weigh
as much as a grizzly bear.
And right now, that's
what this fish feels like.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Pull,
pull, pull, pull, pull.
Think we got it!
ZEB HOGAN: We're
up to the float.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Keep pulling.
Just keep pulling.
Keep pulling.
ZEB HOGAN: Keep pulling.
Just watching my feet.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Keep going,
keep going, keep going.
ZEB HOGAN: Aghh!
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Remember
to watch your hands
on the leader part.
ZEB HOGAN: Yep!
Oh, man, it feels heavy.
Goliath grouper, big one!
Yeah, it looks big.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Ready to get it on board?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Here it comes.
ZEB HOGAN: Nice, awesome, man!
Big fish.
So, first, goliath grouper,
big, man. It's massive!
Towel over the head of
the fish to keep it calm.
A tube in the fish's mouth to
pass water over its gills.
And we're gonna strap it down,
so in case it starts flapping,
it stays secured
to this stretcher.
Check it out, our first
grouper, man, it's a big fish.
They're one of the largest
bony fish on earth.
Grow up to about eight feet
long, over six hundred pounds.
Everything about this
fish is super-sized.
You can see big head,
large mouth, thick lips.
The dorsal spines are almost
the size of one of my fingers.
And this kind of classic
grouper mottled color.
Lighter belly, darker back.
One of the most impressive
things about the goliath
grouper, not necessarily
the length, but its mass,
the thickness, all of the
muscle, the strength.
And that's what I'm feeling
when I'm holding on to that
hand line, is this
fish using its strength
to try to get back down
to the ocean bottom.
JESS: When you're
ready, pull tight,
and let me know
what number you got.
ZEB HOGAN: Okay.
One five three, is that right?
JESS: Yep, one five three.
Awesome!
ZEB HOGAN: This is a
five-foot Goliath grouper.
How much would you
guess this fish weighs?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Probably
around 200 pounds.
ZEB HOGAN: That's a big fish.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Yeah,
that's a big fish.
ZEB HOGAN: Amazingly, this
grouper could get four times
heavier and weigh eight
hundred pounds by the time
it's fully grown.
Chris wants to find out what
the goliath grouper is eating.
And he's figured out a bizarre
but effective way to do
just that with a plastic pipe.
The easiest way to get the
stomach contents is actually
put my hand and my arm all the
way into the fish's belly.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Go all
the way in until you feel
the back of its stomach.
ZEB HOGAN: Ugh!
All the way?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI:
All the way in.
Feel around for anything
that might be in there.
ZEB HOGAN: Oh, gross!
It doesn't smell
very good either!
Feels like I'm putting
my hand into a roast,
or like a raw steak.
I can't tell what
stomach and what's bait.
Oh, there's something in here.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Yeah. Yep.
ZEB HOGAN: Agh!
[LAUGHS]
That's gross.
Agh!
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: It's
partially digested fish parts.
JESS: We'll take it.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: All right.
So, put that in here
as our stomach samples.
So, you can see here, that's
a crab part, right there,
you can also see
fairly small vertebrae,
which will be from
a smaller reef fish,
probably not
something very large.
ZEB HOGAN: I was expecting to
find large fish in this stomach.
The groupers' normal
diet it's not large fish?
It's crabs and smaller fish?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Exactly,
behaviorally, they don't,
they don't swim very fast, so
they're not going to be after
very fast prey, they often
feed into the bottom,
into the sediment.
ZEB HOGAN: Wow. So,
even though the goliath
grouper is able to swallow
a big bait, normally,
grouper feed relatively low
on the food chain, on
crabs and small fish.
And that's an important clue.
This goliath grouper wasn't
searching the ocean looking
for big prey like
those sharks were.
To hook this grouper,
I had to drop my bait
right in front of it on
the ocean bottom.
Okay.
JESS: Hold.
ZEB HOGAN: Okay.
You're ready?
JESS: Clamp it!
Perfect.
ZEB HOGAN: Hey.
Okay. Fish is tagged.
We ready to get this
fish back into water?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: We're ready to
get it back in the water then.
ZEB HOGAN: But before I
can release this grouper,
something big is
hitting my other bait.
Aggghhhhh! Fish on.
Oh, my God, it's huge!
ZEB HOGAN: We got a fish!
It's just like pulling a
sack of cement, isn't it?
Agh, looks like a grouper.
Seeing that pale,
kinda yellow color.
Arghh.
I'm fighting the fish and
the current trying to get it
up behind the boat here.
Let's get a look at it.
Woo, oh, man.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: I'd have
to say that's gonna be
five and half feet long.
ZEB HOGAN: So, we caught
two fish at the same time.
These guys say
that isn't unusual,
once we get the first bite, then
other grouper can sense
what's going on and they'll
come in and feed as well,
creating a feeding frenzy.
So, check out this mouth and
what you can see immediately
it's not like a shark
with sharp, jagged teeth.
On the upper and lower jaw are
pads of needle-like teeth
that are pointed backwards, so
if I put my finger in its mouth,
and try to pull my
finger out, it grips,
so that's exactly what would
happen to prey that ended up
in a grouper's mouth.
They can open their mouth
very, very, very wide,
the grouper will suck
in prey, clamp down,
and use those teeth to grip
on to prey and then swallow
the prey whole.
So, this is an important clue.
Groupers are not biting and
ripping apart prey like a shark,
they're sucking it in
and swallowing it whole.
Which makes total sense now
that I know grouper eat mainly
small fish and crabs, hardly
the diet of a ferocious monster.
It's a re-capture, so this
is a fish that these guys
have already caught
and tagged once.
Okay, tag number 96F2508.
JESS: Got it.
ZEB HOGAN: What are the tags and
re-captures tell you about
the fish's movement patterns?
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: If we're
recapturing this fish
over and over again, that means
that they're likely residence
because they have a very
strong site fidelity,
they don't move a lot during
most time of the year.
ZEB HOGAN: So, that's
an important clue.
Goliath grouper
aren't like sharks,
patrolling large expanses
of ocean looking for prey.
They'll find a wreck
or a reef they like
and make that their home.
Unstrap it first.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Yes.
ZEB HOGAN: Strap's off.
CHRIS MALINOWSKI: Good.
ZEB HOGAN: See you later.
Wow!
Working with Chris and his
research team and catching
two big ocean predators,
I now know that goliath
grouper are misunderstood.
Even though goliath grouper
are big, powerful predators,
they're not feeding on
the top of the food chain.
They're not violently ripping
up prey with their teeth
like some sharks, they're
sucking in prey with their mouth
And goliath grouper aren't
out patrolling the open ocean
like those sharks I caught.
They're sticking to one
chosen reef or wreck,
finding small prey
on the ocean bottom.
So, why are there viral
videos showing them attacking
large prey on the surface?
MAN: Oh, oh, my God!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
ZEB HOGAN: I leave Chris and
travel across state to the Gulf
of Mexico, where some of these
viral videos have emerged.
It's here in the small town of
Englewood where local fishermen
are gonna help me set
the record straight.
I wanna see whether
or not the viral videos
of goliath grouper are true.
And if so, figure out why
a bottom-dwelling fish
is behaving so aggressively
at the surface.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
I'm out with Dan.
He's a Florida local,
a charter boat captain,
and he has encounters with
goliath grouper every day
and this is something I'd
like to see for myself.
We're about five, six
miles offshore here,
fishing above an
artificial reef.
This is a popular fishing reef
where Dan says goliath grouper
come to the surface
to feed aggressively.
Oh, got a nibble.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Got something.
Fish on!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Oh!
Lost the fish.
Something big came
in and got it.
DAN BOURCIER: Yeah, you
probably had about a
three, four-pound fish on there
and then a goliath grouper came
and got him about halfway up.
ZEB HOGAN: So, that's what
people are complaining about.
People come out here to
try to catch smaller fish,
the goliath grouper
come up, whack.
So, I witnessed firsthand a
grouper steal a fish off my line
and I know there is some truth
to those stories I heard.
So, how do you avoid that Dan?
DAN BOURCIER: Well, the best
trick is when you feel that bite
you just reel as quick as you
can to try and get that fish
away from the bottom.
ZEB HOGAN: And so, as soon
as the fish is hooked,
it's a race because there's
probably a big grouper
chasing it?
DAN BOURCIER: You hit
it right on the head.
ZEB HOGAN: Fish, fish!
DAN BOURCIER: There you go!
Get him up, get
him up, get him up!
ZEB HOGAN: Just trying to
get him up as fast as I can.
So, it's a race now
between me and the grouper.
Agh!
God.
DAN BOURCIER: Come on!
Go! Go! Go!
Get him off the bottom. Come on!
ZEB HOGAN: Agh!
Woo!
As long as I reel in fast, get
the fish up to the boat
as quickly as possible,
no problems.
DAN BOURCIER: That extra
two seconds that that fish
either has to rest or to swim
back down, that's all it takes.
Your goliaths are gonna
get 'em most of the time.
ZEB HOGAN: The viral videos make
a lot more sense to me now.
People are going out to
locations that have a lot of
goliath grouper.
They're putting bait in
the water or they have
a weakened fish on the line
and the goliath grouper
are coming in for an easy meal.
MAN: Oh, oh, oh, my God!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
ZEB HOGAN: So, even
though they catch,
the majority of their diet on
the ocean bottom, it's clear,
goliath grouper will
still target a big meal
if it's dangled in front of
them or it's on the surface.
I wanna see if this 'easy meal'
theory explains the attacks
on scuba divers.
To do that, I'm going
out with Tom McLaughlin.
He's been fishing and diving for
over 20 years and has a secret
spot where I can dive
with goliath grouper.
So, where are we
headed right now?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: We're headed
to a big wreck in about
a hundred feet of water.
It's the kind of place
they really like to live.
ZEB HOGAN: The entire wreck
is about 500-feet long,
it's all broken apart.
We're gonna focus in on
one piece of that wreck
where Tom says the grouper
really like to hang out.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
This is my first dive.
We're in about a hundred feet
of water diving on a wreck
where Tom's seen a
lot of groupers.
He's also seen a lot of
big sharks around here,
so I'm excited, feeling
a little bit nervous,
just wanna get in the
water and get down and see
what's down there.
I love the water, but that
sense of not being able to see
what's out there is still a
little bit unnerving.
Out of the murk, the gloom I
see the large shape of a wreck
emerge below me.
And I need to be careful.
Swimming in confined spaces
like this can be dangerous.
There are lots of things
I can get tangled up in.
Suddenly, I look up and in
front of me is a big shadow,
moving in the darkness.
And as my eyes adjust
to the darkness,
I'm face to face
with the grouper.
And I'm not sure how
it's going to react.
It seems to sense my presence
and it slowly moves away.
I'm seeing grouper poking their
heads out of the portholes
in the wreck.
Swimming up a ledge,
peering over a crack,
and seeing a grouper sitting
down in the hole of the wreck.
None of the grouper
are being aggressive.
So, now, I wanna try the
second half of my experiment
and introduce an easy meal.
We're sitting on top of the
wreck and a big school of jacks
swims by us.
The second Tom spears that jack,
the atmosphere
on the wreck changes.
The reef becomes more tense,
more turned on, more energized.
As we're swimming up the wreck,
I see off to my right something
big coming out of the darkness.
It's not a grouper.
It's a bull shark.
One of the most dangerous
sharks in the world.
And it's coming right at us.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
ZEB HOGAN: I see this light
shape coming towards me,
pointed snout, sleek body, more
streamlined than a grouper.
A seven-foot bull shark, it
comes in between Tom and I,
and circles back behind my head.
This isn't a good situation.
A lot of people get bitten
by sharks in exactly
these circumstances.
And it's circling us,
swimming around us.
It's obviously cued in
on that bait as well.
We need to get out
of this situation.
We move down to a crack in
the wreck where we'll be less
vulnerable to the bull shark.
But the crack in the wreck
is where all the grouper
are sitting.
And the grouper are also
behaving differently
because we have this fish.
The grouper are being much more
aggressive, moving more quickly,
obviously interested in
this fish that we have.
I pick up the fish, hold it
out and an instant a grouper
comes in, grabs the whole head
of the fish, of this jack
in its mouth, pulls it
from me and swims away.
We can still see the bull shark
patrolling around the wreck.
So, we need to get back up
to the surface
as quickly as we can.
And so, it's clear
that introducing food
into the equation, it triggers
that grouper feeding behavior.
So, now, I can see that video
in a different way when that
grouper, what it looks like
it's attacking the diver,
it's actually just going after
the food that that diver has.
That's a clue that these grouper
may not be the monsters
that some people
make them out to be.
They're not searching out big
prey or treating humans as food.
They're detecting
small or injured fish
using their lateral line
like most other fish species.
I've yet to catch a fully
grown goliath grouper.
But I've learned these fish only
inhabit certain structures
and rarely move, so I'm gonna
need Tom's help to find a giant.
He's one of the only people on
the west coast who's permitted
to catch and land goliath
grouper for research,
so he knows all the
local grouper hang outs.
This is my opportunity to try
and catch the biggest goliath
grouper I can find and collect
data for local scientists
along the way.
Before we are able to
catch our grouper,
we need to catch our bait.
There are a bunch of birds right
out here in front of the boat,
and I can see action on
the surface of the water.
If we can get right in
the middle of the school,
get some bait.
Oh, yeah, you can see
him on the surface here,
they're right behind the boat.
Just moving my rod back and
forth a little bit to give
that tube just a little
bit of action.
Make it look a little bit
more like a live fish.
They're coming.
We're gonna get a bite.
Yeah, I got one, yeah.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Oh, he's running, got a fish.
Man!
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: And
that's just our bait.
ZEB HOGAN: Yeah,
that's the bait.
It just took like
50 yards of line.
Oh, there it goes!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Nice and this is good bait?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN:
This is great bait.
ZEB HOGAN: Grouper just
eat that thing no problem?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: They definitely
would eat that whole.
Even much bigger fish than
this, they'll eat whole.
ZEB HOGAN: Barracuda can get
up to about six foot long,
and this size is about three,
three and a half feet.
That's an impressive fish.
Long, slender, pointed nose,
relatively large eyes,
and those very sharp,
almost jagged teeth.
They have a reputation for
being very efficient predators.
So, the fish that I'm after
could eat this barracuda
in one bite.
Now, that I've caught
the bait I need,
it's time to catch my
monster-sized grouper.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Where are we headed right now?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: We're gonna go
over to the Phosphate Dock.
It's an abandoned dock,
right on Boca Grande pass.
ZEB HOGAN: So, this is kind of a
local spot that's known to have
some big fish?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: There're a lot
of records of catching fish
in the 400 and 500 pound range.
ZEB HOGAN: We're fishing
for a 400 or 500 pound fish,
essentially in
people's backyards.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
The grouper, they're actually
in between those pilings.
Their heads pointed out.
And we're gonna try
to back the boat in,
I'm gonna drop the bait down.
As soon as I feel the
bite, I'm gonna reel in,
Tom's gonna drive the boat
away from those pilings
and see if we can land a fish.
Ready?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Yep.
ZEB HOGAN: Drop it?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Yep. Drop it!
ZEB HOGAN: So, I wanna keep the
bait about two or three feet off
the bottom, just keep
the bait real still,
so we can see when
we get a bite.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Okay, I'm on the bottom there,
reeled up a little bit.
Just wait for that
rod tip to bend.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Oh, bite, got one, got one!
Oh.
No, no. Man!
So, they're down there,
they're able to move back
into those pilings
and I can't hook 'em.
On the bottom.
Reel up a little bit.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Getting, there's something.
Got a hit!
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: That's
your bite. Yep, reel!
ZEB HOGAN: Reel!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Yeah!
Got one!
Fish on!
Holy!
Whoa!
Fish on!
Got something here!
It's back behind the
boat, it's pulling line.
Strong, shaking its head,
making another dive.
It's pushing back down
towards the depths,
we're gonna try to get this
fish away from the pilings.
It's coming up, it's coming up.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
A grouper.
Look at him, shaking
his head back and forth.
Wow. Nice fish.
Whoo! Look at that.
Tom's gonna drive the
boat over to the beach,
we're gonna park quickly
so Tom and I can tag
and release this fish.
Okay, we have the
grouper to shore.
We're gonna put it in this net.
Get a closer look.
So, this is the first time
I have seen a juvenile
live grouper.
So, by comparison,
this is a small guy.
So, Tom, how can you
tell this is a juvenile?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: So, it's partly
the coloration, this mottling.
ZEB HOGAN: So, do you
think that as young fish,
this mottling is
almost a camouflage?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Absolutely.
ZEB HOGAN: This fish here
spent the last several years
growing up in the mangroves,
in the estuary, somewhere safe,
starting to maybe now, get
a little bit more bold,
venturing into deeper water.
Four feet, two inches and
now, we wanna get it tagged.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Okay, it's tagged.
Tag number five seven five four.
This isn't my big grouper,
but it's a big clue.
Catching a juvenile and not a
giant is a sign that fully grown
adults might have left this
location and started
their annual migration
offshore to spawn.
And so, the best chance for a
really big fish is offshore?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Most
of those big fish,
they're gonna be offshore
spawning right now.
ZEB HOGAN: We're just gonna hold
him upright, he's swimming,
you can see the tail moving.
He's ready to go.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Awesome.
Tom thinks that the giant
grouper might be spawning
offshore.
And when groupers do
that, they aggregate,
forming large clusters to breed.
So, my timing could be perfect,
if I can locate where these fish
spawn, I could find
not one, but a whole bunch
of monster sized grouper.
And there's one place
Tom wants to check first.
So, where are we
headed right now?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Here's
our boat right here,
we're headed towards the wreck.
It's a giant freighter that
sunk, it's upside down,
kinda broken apart,
full of holes.
ZEB HOGAN: So, we're in 95
feet of water right now, so
you can see this line
here is the bottom.
This blip, right below
us, is the wreck,
and then a big school of fish
hanging out above the wreck.
This big school of fish might
be the aggregation of giants
we're looking for.
But there's only one
way I can know for sure.
I drop into the water and
the clarity is not good,
there's a strong current.
I'm swimming along,
looking in portholes.
No grouper.
Looking into cracks.
Maybe this was a false alarm.
Maybe there aren't
any fish down here.
And then, as I come around
the front of the boat
all of these grouper
just appear before me.
Six, ten, fifteen just
stretching out as far
as I can see in the distance.
They're the size of small cars.
I'm swimming right into the
middle of a huge aggregation
of one of the largest
fish on earth.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
You only see something like
this, a few places in the world.
And here they are.
All of these goliath grouper
right in front of me.
Ready to spawn
with the new moon.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Man that was one of the
coolest things I've ever seen.
Nothing could really prepare
me for seeing all of them
together like that.
Fifteen giant
grouper all together.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
I've struck gold!
Now, that I've found where
the true giants are hiding,
it's time to catch one!
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Yep, as fast
as you can, there you go.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
ZEB HOGAN: It's running
towards the wreck.
We caught this fish, hooked
this fish about 30 feet
above the bottom.
And he's running back down to
the bottom and I don't want him
to get snagged on anything.
It's making its third run.
Aghh.
Whoa!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
ZEB HOGAN: He's
pulling the boat,
moving the boat over
the wreck, making dives,
but I got some line on him now.
Trying to make another run.
Ohhhh.
Just had a huge run, so with
this rod and this reel,
anytime I can reel, I'm reeling.
Unless the fish is running.
All right, my arms are burning.
See what we got here!
Oh, there we go!
I see something down
there, a silhouette.
It looks big whatever it is.
Whoooo! Oh! It is a
grouper, goliath grouper,
he's right out here
in front of the boat,
he's coming up to the surface.
Nice! Big fish!
Beautiful color.
This one is a little bit bigger,
probably five and a
half feet long.
Beautiful brown, mottled color.
So, you can see this
technique the big rod,
it worked in about 60 seconds.
Okay, you ready?
One, two, three.
[LAUGHTER]
Hold on.
That is a big fish! Whooo!
Man! Nice!
Now, that we've got it on board,
we need to tag it and record
the size and weight for
Tom's research team.
Oh, man, the technique works.
Deep water, fishing
on a wreck, big bait,
and the biggest
goliath grouper yet.
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: So, we're gonna
just keep him nice and wet here.
And then, put this saltwater
hose across his gills
and that's gonna allow him to
breathe while he's in the boat.
ZEB HOGAN: So, we're on a
clock right now, five minutes,
get the tagging done, get
a length, get a weight,
and get this fish
back in the water.
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Five
feet four inches.
ZEB HOGAN: Five
feet four inches,
so almost as long as I am tall.
I'm guessing probably a
hundred and twenty pounds
and believe it or not, they
get a lot bigger than this one.
We got the length;
we got the tag,
time to get this fish
back in the water.
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Yep.
ZEB HOGAN: And gone.
That was the biggest goliath
grouper I've seen so far.
But we're not catching
any true monsters.
Where are the seven
and eight foot grouper?
I wanna try increasing the
size of my bait, so first,
I'm gonna have to catch
some bigger bait fish.
There's a school
right in front of us,
hundreds of fish just
splashing on the surface.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Oh, look at that!
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Bull shark!
ZEB HOGAN: Bull shark!
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: And
another bull shark!
ZEB HOGAN: Fish on!
Agh!
Two sharks right
behind the boat!
I'm gonna try to get this fish
in before the sharks come up.
Oh!
Come on, come on!
There are two big bull sharks
circling right below the boat
though and they will come up
and take this Bonito
right off the line.
Just trying to bring it up to
the surface as fast as I can.
Aghhh!
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
If we can get three or
four of these bonito,
we have a good chance
to the big grouper.
Powerful fish!
It's a bait fish, but
it's a good sized fish.
It's like maybe a
two or three footer.
Whoa!
Phew!
I've beaten the bull
sharks to my bait!
Nice!
Beautiful!
This is the perfect-size to
catch a massive grouper.
Little Bonita, it looks like
a little tuna and they swim
like a tuna, too.
Real powerful burst of speed.
Believe it or not, a goliath
grouper can swallow this whole.
Cool! Okay. Let's get
it in the bait box.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
We keep fishing until we
have six or seven bonita.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Got one?
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Yep!
[LAUGHS]
ZEB HOGAN: Ahhh! I got one!
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: There he is.
ZEB HOGAN: Two fish on!
Ugh.
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Yup!
Perfect bait size.
ZEB HOGAN: This is the bait
that we need to go after
a really big fish.
TOM MCLAUGHLIN: Yep, go!
ZEB HOGAN: Fish on!
Whoa fish, fish, fish!
Come on! Shhh,
no, no, no, no, no.
ZEB HOGAN: That
didn't take long.
Man, as soon as that bait is in
the water, something bites it,
and this is something bigger.
It's almost impossible to
pull line off this reel
and this fish is doing it.
It's bending the rod
down into the water,
this feels like a larger fish.
Whoa!
This is the biggest
fish I've had so far.
So, I need to remember
everything I've learned.
Come on, come on, come on,
come on, grab the lines!
Yeah!
It's pulling a lot of line.
This fish has pulled more line.
Oh, it's hard to
get any line on him.
He's really swimming.
Oh, this could be a big fish.
He's running for that wreck.
It's hard reeling in.
It feels big.
This could be it!
This could be the fish!
Oh!
As fast as I'm reeling in, the
fish is pulling line back out.
The boat is being pulled
from side to side.
This is a 32 foot, 18,000
pound boat that's being pulled
by a fish.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Getting it now, oh, it's
coming up, it's coming up.
Ohhh...
Woo! Man, this is the big one.
This is it!
I've done it, it's amazing.
It's the fish I've
been looking for.
A monster sized grouper,
but it's so big,
it's gonna be impossible for
Tom and I to lift this fish
into the boat.
So, I'm gonna get a length, tag
it, and release it in the water.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
It took all the strength I
had, the tricks I've learned,
Tom's help, to get this
thing up to the surface.
Now, that I'm in the
water with this fish,
I can see just how
big it really is.
Seven feet long, about
three hundred pounds.
Just massive.
It's longer than I am tall.
The girth of it, I probably
couldn't put my arms around it.
The spines are almost as long
and as thick as my fingers.
Check out the size of its tail.
This is a big, big fish.
I mean, a lot of people
say these groupers
are very aggressive, but
being in the water with it,
I can see it for what it is.
They're not being aggressive,
they're not trying
to attack people.
It's just sitting there calmly.
No danger to me whatsoever.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
So, what I've learned is that
the majority of their food
they're finding on the bottom,
in a small, localized territory.
And they're more curious
than they are aggressive
when it comes to humans.
And they're only coming to the
surface where people are fishing
to get an easy meal.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Even the biggest of these
fish are not the menace
or the monster that they're
sometimes made out to be.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪
Fish is recovered.
It's ready to go.
Just gonna take it out
away from the boat.
Give it a push down.
It's gonna be gone.
♪ [MUSIC] ♪